but we have a recession and what I want
to do is to make sure that this
recession is shallower and hurts people
less so we have been careful in a very
balanced approach to make sure that
we're not making that situation worse
but as soon as the recession is behind
us then yes we we consolidate to make
sure that we're balancing our books and
I think that's what people would want do
you acknowledge that living standards
are falling for everyone
living standards are going down that is
the uncomfortable situation facing us
and countries like Germany that are
seeing their growth forecasts go down by
even more than us
and what can we do with our plan for
stability in our plan for growth well
the office for Budget responsibility
which is an independent organization
they say that what we're doing will
reduce the impact of that fall in living
standards by half next year so we are
helping every bit as much as we can
and we're also saying to people that as
we do that we're protecting the public
services that really matter the NHS
schools the things that are going to
help us get through to the other side
and become a really strong Dynamic
economy which is what we all want you
said there'll be 30 billion pounds of
spending cuts which departments are
going to be impacted
well what we've said is that the
unprotected department so places other
than the NHS and schools will have to
absorb the increases in inflation they
they had a generous settlement last year
but that was before Ukraine and and the
gas price increases so it's going to be
challenging for them and I I don't
pretend any differently but overall over
the five-year period we've basically
protected spending because we recognize
that a strong economy needs strong
Public Services we need an NHS to get
people back to work we need schools to
educate people for the future so it's a
balanced package that recognizes that we
need good Public Services